[Music]
and continuing our coverage on that
crash that killed nine in north las
vegas over the weekend now what the
national transportation safety board
says may be needed to prevent similar
events in the future
investigators say the at fault driver
may have been going more than 100 miles
an hour running a red light northbound
on commerce at cheyenne listen closely
to what the ntsb's tom chapman said
monday about crashes involving speed
tragedies such as this compel us to
evaluate the potential for improving
safety by incorporating speed limiting
technology in all vehicles you heard
them right the board may be looking into
speed limiting technology in all
vehicles now there are already speed
governors on some rental trucks where
they just won't go any faster than 65
miles an hour no word on what a possible
top speed might be on passenger cars and
any technology like that would have a
lot of hurdles to overcome sure wouldn't
happen anytime soon but this is the
subject i think we're all going to be
talking about more especially in some of
these future reports and i want to hear
what you think buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone the address
traffic 8 8newsnow.com